thanks a lot Ken for organizing this in
mark this is this is a great event and
just wonderful to see so many friends
from economics and people I've heard
about in and read and admired from
climatology and other areas and it's
good to see you
so I I'm an economist but for those of
you who are not in economics you may be
interested to know that you can't get a
PhD in economics without essentially get
a PhD in statistics as well
so we torture our graduate students by
well I should say by putting them
through econometrics just and
particularly Yale which is a place where
we we like to think we're really good in
econometrics so we we go through that
and anybody who's been through the
graduate program here knows about it so
I actually want to talk about statistics
more than than anything else more than
economics but it's it and it's
statistics that I think would be
relevant for our economic models I hope
you think will be relevant and is
actually applied to some climate data so
let me motivate this so there was a
recent so I want to motivate this with a
lesson from finance there was you me I'm
sure you know there's this recent Nobel
Prize including to a Yale economist for
finance yeah I was actually in economics
but it was really finance and I think as
I looked at that the lesson from those
the three people were that what they
were doing was they were taking
combination of powerful theory very very
rich data and the data in finance are
richer than any place else in economics
and very sophisticated use of statistics
and getting really rich findings really
powerful findings and the the the one
that I am particularly I just live in
awe of is the the history of the
discovery of the random walk hypothesis
all of you probably know that stocks are
supposed to move like a random walk the
history this is really interesting
because it goes back to some physics and
then picked up by economists appetit I'm
particularly to dis a misson and then
fama and Schiller who took roughly the
same data and got pretty much opposite
conclusions but that's okay
they were farmer was looking at the very
very short run and Schiller was looking
at the very very long run and here's a
paper that I some of my time
I'm sure Marty remembers this and Jeff
heel but I remember reading this paper
that Paul Samuelson Road and I remember
when I read it I just couldn't believe
it
the the the the proof that perfectly
anticipated prices fluctuate randomly
and that is such a counter intuitive
notion that somehow when you anticipate
things perfectly they move randomly I
just remember when I first read that I
just I just shook my head I just said
this is just like it just it was I
suppose like quantum physics the
discovery of relativity it's just like
it shook the whole way I thought about
the world and I won't go into this but
it's a it's a it's a beautiful paper he
has some historical roots as well but
then this was basically what farmer and
others used this theorem and then put it
to data and some pretty interesting
statistics too and then we have where we
are today which is the idea of the
random walk hypothesis and all its
implications for finance good and bad
for finance and and we're crashes and
things like that so now I wonder I'm a
little this is a little provocative but
I just want just raising a question
whether might be also in some of the key
parameters that we're using in that we
need for our models and we some we've
talked about today some we haven't
whether you we it might be a fruitful
approach there to use I am impressed as
I look at climatology and
paleoclimatology a beautifully rich data
it's just amazing the data I just the
ice core data I think is just one of the
most beautiful data sets of data I've
ever seen in my life I just am in awe of
those data and the combination of that
and some
statistics and theory might actually
give us some interesting results and I
don't want to be too negative but it
looks to me as if there are some
diminishing returns in building more and
more models now maybe we just haven't
hit that threshold we just you get down
to more resolution and faster computers
and you know the super hyper computers
and maybe we're gonna cross some
threshold where it's just when we get
down to one kilometer resolution that's
where the problem is and when we get
down there everything will suddenly
become clear maybe so I don't know but
they're they're pretty clearly just as
you look at what's happened we haven't
we haven't resolved things like the
temperature sensitivity okay so that's
so I'll just say I have to have two
puzzles I'm only going to talk about one
in detail but I do think there's this is
this diagram which Ken showed earlier
and many of you from the climate
scientists know this from the fifth
assessment report this question sort of
the distribution of PDFs and then the
distribution of the distribution of PDFs
and then this common it this this
strange combination at the bottom that I
haven't yet to understand how that was
arrived at but one question is whether
we we could better use these results in
the spirit of meta analysis which is
used in it's not used we're not used at
all in economics I don't know if it's
used in climate and climate and earth
sciences but in a spirit of meta
analysis whether we can combine these
data to improve the precision now I know
Jeff doesn't like this Jeff he'll
doesn't like this idea because he he
wants to he doesn't want to see these
and I sympathize at that point of view
but but from the point of view of this
classical statistics whether we could
improve these combinations it's a very
complicated problem because these are
not independent so these are not
independent clinical trials we didn't
get a thousand patients from here and a
thousand patients from there a lot of
them are quite dependent they're using
the same data the same data sets so I
have to be very careful but I do think
this it will be very fruitful
for some statistician who's interested
in meta analyses to see how you could
take these combine them take into
account the dependencies among the
different data sets and get a some kinds
of combinations maybe that was how it
was done but I I can and I are trying to
track down how it was done and we've
been worrying about this maybe can since
I last talked to you knows how the
combinations have been done but any one
I would be very grateful if any of you I
would probably be on my knees like like
Hank Paulson with Nancy Pelosi I would
get on my knees if you just could tell
me how they were done okay but that's
not what to talk about what I want to
spend my 10 minutes or so on is so is
this untangling the Paleo climatic data
I think all of us must have looked at
this this something like this which is
the co2 and temperature proxy data over
the last 400,000 years yes I'm sorry all
right sorry so you you missed you missed
half of it but there it's okay well it
wasn't was it worth it wasn't worth
hearing so this is the second half so I
as I said I'm sure all of us have looked
at that and and it's kind of something's
going on here you just can't you know
and of course some people say oh co2 is
obvious that co2 is causing temperature
change you know just look at this
diagram and other people resist that but
something going on here can't we on take
it untangle that and of course this was
the first thing that comes to mind which
is the chicken and which is the egg here
and that's this is a good good question
so I assume that's the reason we haven't
figured it out is because there's a
chicken and egg problem so what I'd like
to suggest so this is something that
would be familiar to many of the
economists but maybe not
to the earth scientists but I think what
I'd like to suggest is there is a
technique that might be useful in a lot
of applications of statistics to the
geosciences where you have multiple data
that are going on at the same time with
chickens and eggs and you don't know the
directionality which is called
simultaneous equation estimation or
instrumental variable estimation there's
a little different but for this purpose
they're about the same and I assume that
not all of you know about it or I would
I will just end if you all know about it
but it's worth talking about so we know
that the co2 and the tio highly
correlated from that picture but it's
not it's not obviously extent in the
direction of the feedbacks and now some
I'm sorry now I must geo scientists have
talked to a mark and I have talked about
this have a pretty clear view about
what's going on but the question is
whether you can use statistical analysis
to either confirm or not confirm that
and so this is what I want to do is
suggest you can use an instrumental
variable approach to find out which is
chicken and which is egg there's a
little bit of history there there's a
paper by Kaufman Copley in stock which
is not quite on the subject and then
there's a really interesting paper by
Derek Lemoine which is almost
identically on the doubtless same
subject although he did it a little
differently and so in a way what I'm
doing is showing what Lemoine showed in
his paper but you know slightly
different he used a slightly different
framework okay so let me go through the
statistics quickly so what I want to
assume is you have a system like this
where you have you have temperature as a
function of co2 co2 as a function of
temperature there are some exogenous
forcing variables m and Z the random
errors but now you can you put lags in
here it's not going to change and now
put lags when I do the empirical but
purpose of this you want to say that
that both effect the other we talk a lot
about co2 concentrations affecting
temperature but we also know that it
goes the other way around so they keep
the key inside is whether key question
these are there other variables that
affect temperature and concentration but
don't affect the other
so are there variables which are
exogenous that affect these but don't
have a don't that affect the chicken but
don't affect the egg and the one that
I'm going to particularly focus on is is
well let me just say oh just the this
yields in just to go through a couple of
technical points this will yield what's
known as a reduced form which is a
technical term from statistics well what
I've done is I've I've taken this and
I've solved for the left hand side
variables as a function of the exogenous
variables and the disturbances but we've
removed the simultaneity from this so
there all of these are either exogenous
variables or they're random independent
errors and then you can actually so if
if you go if these if you solve this
you're gonna come up with if you do
rental or near least squares estimate
you're gonna run you're gonna get an
estimate of this which is actually not
equal to alpha and it's actually you can
show with a little work it's actually
gonna be greater than alpha but it's
gonna be a function of the variance of
the errors the variance I've taken out
I've taken out the Z because it's not
important for this the variance of the M
and the variance of the use so unless
you're very very lucky and some of the
video variances are zero you're gonna
get a biased coefficient and generally
you'll get a coefficient it's biased
upwards now what I'm going to do do
later is I'm going to use orbital
variables Milankovitch orbital variables
as instruments here and the key
assumption is that the orbital variables
affect the climate but they don't affect
co2 concentrations except through their
effect through climate right so now
maybe it's wrong maybe when
precession occurs a little rock
weathering occurs or something like that
but I think probably not I think it
probably is the case that if but it's
critical to this that it affects co2
concentrations only through its effect
on climate now we the Z variable would
be the opposite effects that affects
vivo affects the carbon concentrations
without affecting the climate and I
don't know of a Z very well
unfortunately it's really too bad but if
we had a Z variable we would really be
very very happy
pups okay so the key point though is if
you have a simultaneous system the
reason you can't you can't untangle that
chicken egg because you have a
simultaneous equation bias which is it's
the difference this is a complicated
tangle of things and it just takes a
little takes a little work to prove
that's greater than then alpha that's
assuming that the beta and the theta
they are positive or the beta actually
that the beta is positive so now so
they're two couple of points at first
these equations do not identify that's a
technical term it means you can't figure
out what the parameters are without
further assumptions so one approach is
to use these orbital variables I've done
a lot of instrumental variable work over
my long life and I've never seen so
actually such a beautiful set of
instrumental variables maybe time is
exaggerate
almost every other instrumental variable
we use in economics you can think of
some indirect feedback effect but it
actually looks I'm sure I'm gonna be
told I'm wrong but it sure looks to me
as if orbital variables are ones that
affect the climate but don't directly
affect co2 and if that's the case then
you're really really a happy
statistician now as I say I in my
conversations with people have not found
any instruments to identify co2 so if
you have some did you know about let me
know
if you could do that you could get a lot
further we could only solve half the
problem with with this set of
identification assumptions there so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go and
identify the parameter the feedback
parameter goes to the parameter from
temperature to co2 that we can very very
closely identify but we can't identify
the temperature sensitivity coefficient
from co2 to T because we don't have an
instrument there it might be possible to
use higher order moments to do that but
I and that's very popular in economic
kind of metrics but I don't like it very
much because it's less I think much less
persuasive and it requires all kinds of
assumptions but I think it's possible
you could do that too but I haven't done
that today okay so let me just show you
so what I did was the equation was just
so the simple equation of log of carve
co2 concentrations on temperature
temperature and log of co2
concentrations with these random
variables and then the Milankovitch
variables in the temperature equation
and then if you run an ordinary least
squares estimate of that you get a
parameter of 0.02 - 4 which is actually
pretty close to what you get in some of
the general circulation models I'm told
if you run it with an IV estimate
you get almost identical estimate which
is actually quite surprising and just so
that you know here I don't really know
what I mean I would use advice here but
presumably that climatologists would
know what the relevant lags are clearly
is not just current orbital variables
with current and lag orbital variables I
just used current lag one killer years
and 5000 years
once you use those it doesn't seem to
make much difference to the estimates
you could put in 10,000 or 3,000 it's
about basically the same results the
date okay the data set is what I'll call
the standard data set the most Vostok
ice core proxy and co2
and the Malak of itch is standard
Milankovitch data there are a lot of
I'll get if we wanted some there are a
lot of technical issues statistical
issues that mean this is it's a little
more complicated than the story I'm
telling for lots of reasons
interpolation auto regressive errors
moving average errors interpolated data
all kinds of issues and rise that but I
think those are those are technical
issues well I want to show is that
there's a technique you can use to
disentangle the chicken and egg so what
this does suggest is that the fact that
these coefficients are close is that
most of the variation is coming from the
orbitally driven temperature and then it
does it actually gives you a pretty
clean estimate of of what the feedback
is and it says that if you have a three
temp three degree rise that if your
concentrations are 500 ppm that you'd
get an additional feedback effect of
about 33 ppm which i think is in the
ballpark of some of the models I've
looked at so I think I think the main
the main takeaway here is there is a
technique where you can break this
chicken and egg problem it requires a
lot of very careful data work which I
haven't done and a lot of careful
examination of what kind of biases there
are particularly in the estimates
because of the air properties of the
residuals but it can be done just so
they disappear from this data set this
shows you the actual co2 concentrations
in blue and then the other two lines are
the estimates of the amount that are
driven by temperature in the OLS burner
least-squares which is in green and the
instrumental variable which is in red
and you can see they're very close not
perfect they get the major cycle but the
main thing is that it looks as if that
you can use this and they're not a
there's not a huge bias in the OLS in
that parameter anyway
now so you could actually go back and
estimate the temperature equation I did
this and this this is the this is the
Alpha parameter you multiply that by
about 0.62 to get the temperature
sensitivity that's the temperature
sensitivity and Antarctica but this is
an upper bound from the theorem on the
bias this is an upper bound and so I
actually think that this I presented
this once when Marty was there and he
didn't like it he told me how all the
mistakes that were there's there still
are there oh I did a little more to take
into account his comment but in terms of
I thought I depth when I first did this
how can we chop off that upper tail in
Marty's fat tail distribution and I I
would claim modestly I mean that
modestly then actually this is a way of
chopping off the upper tail because we
know that it's pretty tightly determined
you can see from the t-statistic there
although it's probably biased downward
the biased upward you can see that it's
a pretty well determined coefficient and
we know that this is we know that this
is upward bias of the true alpha and
just so that's if we take multiply that
by the log of two that gives you eight
point seven degree sensitivity vostok
upper limit and I used a point six three
to five ratio to get global which gets
you down about five for an upper limit
now I think you can do better than this
if you're looking at the error variances
but I haven't quite figured out how and
so I'll just leave it at that okay so
I'm gonna wrap up so I think so what
I've suggested is that the combination
of good theory good data and statistics
can actually bring information to this
question that's a pretty great answers
at least to economists and I think
actually more broadly but we the
instrumental variable can only at this
point reliably do the temperate the co2
temperature
part of because we only have that one
set of instruments and we can't yet due
to the TCO - and can't do the co2 T
which is actually what we're probably
more interested in and to do the co2 T
equation we would need an instrument as
I said something that affects co2
concentrations without affecting
temperature so if you could if you can
think of something something I don't
know I don't know what it would be some
fantastic thing maybe there's some solar
thing the leads to greater weather I
have no idea but I'm sure mark does but
something that is what leads to I mean
if volcanoes burped up vast quantities
of co2 and we're excited us that would
be the kind of thing you might think but
you need something that's independent of
the climate that's burping up co2 that
you can measure and you can identify and
if you can find that then you can do the
other equation and I'd be very
interested in your ideas so so that's